of course twice after verse two
okay are we
[Music]
[Applause]
hello
welcome to the table we are glad to have
each one of you here
my name is don jacobs i'm part of the
leadership team here um at the table and
it's my pleasure just to
say hello we are glad that you're here
um and just to you know greet you
one quick announcement that i have
is that we are going to be doing a trunk
or treat at the end of the month so the
end of this month you probably already
heard this you're going to continue
hearing about this but at the end of
this month we are actually having
halloween on sunday so we are planning a
trunk or treat um
uh event so more information is going to
be coming out about that but just kind
of make sure you just kind of keep that
back your mind
with that being said i'm going to start
off with prayer and then we'll get
started with worship
laura thank you so much for bringing us
here today
thank you for
uh just this ability to be together and
to just gather um together and to learn
more about you and just your
um
just where you want us to be uh just in
your relationship with you lord
i pray you open up our hearts our minds
um just to no matter what we've had this
week
i know what we no matter what we have
thinking about that's whatever is
weighing on our hearts swinging our
minds i pray that we can just bring them
here
bring them bring them to you and just
know that you love us
and that we can bring them to you and
you will just give us peace
and christ's name pray amen
amen
thank you john
all right you guys um if you are
comfortable doing so if you all stand we
are gonna
get started noel's gonna start us off
tonight with a song called multiplied
and we just invite each one of you
whether you know it or not if you're
comfortable sing along it's
worship is an opportunity not just for
the people on the stage but it's an
opportunity for all of us as a community
to join in together and speak truths
that we believe
um
who who god is and how he
engages us in our life and as a
community so y'all just enter into this
moment with us it is an all play
so um
all right
[Music]
your love is
like radiant diamonds
[Music]
bursting inside us
we cannot
contain
your love will
[Music]
surely come find us
like blazing wildfires
singing your name
[Music]
to your desires
stretch across the skies
[Music]
is
bursting inside us
we cannot
come today
[Music]
[Applause]
i
[Music]
lay this
these
[Music]
sweet
may be
[Music]
is
[Applause]
hallelujah
[Music]
okay
a man's empty praise
[Music]
you came along
they put me back together
and every desire
is now satisfied
[Music]
though here nothing
better than you
there's nothing
nothing is better than you
[Music]
but i'm not afraid
to show you my weakness
[Music]
this god of the mountains
is god of the valley
[Music]
and there's not a place
for mercy and grace
go find me again
[Music]
no there's nothing
better than you love there's nothing
better than your lord there's nothing
nothing is better than you
though there's nothing
[Music]
nothing is better than you
you turn morning to dancing
[Music]
you give beauty for ashes
you turn shame into glory
you're the only one who cares
you turn graves into gardens
you turn bones into armies
you turn seasons to
highways you're the only one who cares
singing
though there's nothing
better than you oh
[Music]
nothing is better
nothing is better than you
turn morning to dancing
you turn morning to dancing
you get beauty
you turn shame into glory
you're the only one who cares
[Music]
you turn seasons to highways
you're the only one who cares
[Music]
yeah
all right we're gonna go ahead and move
into our prayers of the people
and if this is your first time with us
this is just a time during our service
where we want to take a moment to lift
up the things that we're carrying on our
hearts and as a community
make space for each other and some of
the stress or the pain or just the
concern that you may have maybe it's
someone in your life who's struggling
and you've been
um holding them dear right now and
lifting them up during this time maybe
it's a situation going on in our nation
or our world that's just heavy on your
heart and we just invite you to bring
this
bring this out and lift it up and
believe together that
jesus is with us in the midst of our
pain and he's hearing us
so i'm going to read through this prayer
and then i'll make space for each of us
to
pray out whatever it is that's on your
heart tonight
and then i will close it out with
another short prayer and if you're
joining us online we will be watching in
the comment section so feel free to
leave a comment that's on your heart and
we will share that here in our service
so that we can also be caring with you
guys as well
together
for the city of saxi texas and for every
city and community and all of those who
live in them
we pray to you
and jesus for the good earth that you
have given us in the wisdom and the will
to conserve it
we pray to you
for those who travel on land sea or air
for the old and the sick for the widow
and orphan for the injured and suffering
we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and the destitute for
prisoners and captives and for all who
remember and care for them
we pray to you
lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us
so right now we lift these names and
situations up to you
[Music]
terry ramsey
from online
nancy's chemo treatment
and unspoken prayer requests
and prayer for our staff
students teachers and staff members
[Music]
mental health
jesus for the names and moments that
we've spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts
we pray to you that they may have life
and light and healing and hope
peace
and a deep sense of your presence
amen
[Music]
as we move into this next song
i'm just reminded especially whenever we
take time
to share our burdens together that
sometimes
the strongest thing that we can do is
confess our weaknesses
and i can be the poster child for that
today because i spent a good majority of
the day
stressing and crying about things going
on in my life and feeling
so hesit to share them
because it's hard sometimes to admit
when we need help you know it's hard to
say i don't have it together it's hard
to say
i
am struggling
and i feel like that's one of the
beauties of that tradition that we're
trying to bring into our service is is
just um
naming sometimes that we all have
struggles we all are carrying things
we're human beings we have feelings and
hearts and we bring all of those into
this room together and
i don't want to miss the opportunity to
shoulder to those together i don't want
to miss the opportunity to see each
other in our humanness and say i believe
god is meeting us right there i believe
that he wants to be
in the valley with us just as much as he
wants to meet us on the mountain
i don't want to miss the opportunity to
acknowledge
that god is with us
he is sharing in our life
when i'm strong and especially when i'm
weak and confessing that sometimes just
naming it just
voicing it is what i need
to allow him to be god instead of
assuming that i'm supposed to be god
that i'm supposed to keep it together
and look like
um i'm making everything work because
i'm not
[Music]
and thank god for community who allows
us to be that together you know thank
god that we have one another
that's why we're the body of christ
not just the hand or the foot or the eye
but the whole body coming together so in
this next song i just want us to leave
space for our own struggles and just
being honest with god open with god
about where we're at and and maybe give
yourself permission to just say i don't
have a lot to offer right now
i don't have it all together
but my heart is yours
my intention is to be here with you and
to to allow you to meet me in this
moment
so i just i wanted to share that because
that's what's going on in my life just
um
learning to be vulnerable
learning to
look like a mess sometimes in and find
peace right there
so i hope that you guys feel the freedom
as well to be where you're at tonight
because there is certainly room in the
presence of god for all of our mess and
all our crap
he's already aware of it so let's share
it okay
[Music]
how can i respond
to the love that you have
lavished on
me
how can i respond
to the love that you have lavish on
me
i don't have much
but i have a heart that beats for you
i have a heart that beats for you
i don't have much
but i have a heart that beats for you i
have a heart that beats for you
[Music]
every part of me
wants to love you like you've loved me
my lord
i don't have much
but i have a heart that beats for you
[Music]
i don't have much
but i have a heart that beats for you
i have a heart that beats for you and i
have a heart that beats for you
i have a heart that beats for you i have
a heart that beats
[Music]
i have a life i'll give to you
i have a heart that feeds for you i have
a heart that beats for you
i have a heart that beats for you and i
have a heart that beats for you
i don't have much
[Music]
but i have a heart that beats for you
i have a heart that feeds for you
i don't have much
but
[Music]
thank you god
that you make room for us
[Music]
and not only that but that we find you
in our stories we find you in our
brokenness and in our mess
[Music]
thank you that you
hold all things together
that you hold our hearts
and our stories and our lives
you know our past that sometimes plagues
us
[Music]
you see our weaknesses
and you love us
you meet us there
and you turn our ashes into beauty
you turn our seas into highways god
[Music]
that's who you are
and we lean into that tonight we ask you
to keep doing your good work in our
hearts
[Music]
help us
to surrender to that work
help us to pursue health even when it's
hard
[Music]
help us to be vulnerable
to let go
[Music]
and allow you to come and do your good
work
[Music]
i love you god and i love this community
i love these people who have made space
for my story
who have made room for my mess
god would we continue to be that in this
world would we continue to make space
and to believe for others that you are
here doing your thing that you're
meeting us
that you are changing us as we allow you
to god
help us to lean into it
and give us ears to hear what's on
brett's hearts tonight
god let it change us from the inside out
[Music]
amen if you guys want to turn and say
hello to the people around you brett's
going to come up and get us started with
the message
well hello hello
good evening everybody
grace and peace
um
my name is brett
i'm the pastor here
and it's just wonderful wonderful to
welcome all of you and um that of course
oh
that sounded intense was that our banner
our mysterious but hopefully this one
holds we'll see
um
well i wanted to um also welcome those
joining us online
um
we love you lots i hope uh i know the
sound team was working frantically to
try to get things uh going well online
we this is our first time with a new
sound system
um so you know we're working out the
kinks and figuring all that out and uh
so at any rate we love you online even
if you know we're still um figuring out
our tech for you sorry if it was it was
a little bit rough
um
and i also want to welcome those of you
who are new
and um just kind of you know settling in
finding finding your um way to the table
where uh we're just yeah grateful
grateful that you're here and we really
long to be
um
just a you know an inclusive
people
um welcoming hospitable that's really
our heart so uh at any rate i hope that
you you know since that you can you can
start to feel that and pick up on that
so all right yeah we are kicking off a a
brand new series tonight
it is titled first peter
uh part one
the reason uh it's part one is because
well as you probably picked up we're
going to be walking through the book of
first peter
but i was going to try to cover the
whole book in five weeks because that's
right before advent
which is kind of the christmas season in
the church calendar um and i thought you
know that's crazy like no i can't do
that so what we're going to do is we'll
just take this in kind of pieces so i'm
going to do chapter one we'll work on
chapter one
through um up until advent
so
that'll let us kind of settle in a
little bit and take things you know nice
and slow and really be able to chew on
and kind of understand the book um if
you've been around the table for a while
you know that we kind of do different
types of series sometimes we'll do more
topical like we just finished a whole
series on deconstruction um and you know
kind of wrestling with faith and doubt
and all those things so the times we'll
do more topical things other times we'll
do um kind of jump on the church
calendar like we will for advent and do
things like that and then other times
we'll do just like a book of the bible
so that's what we're doing with uh with
first peter so just to give you i want
to start with a little bit of background
on the book um for those who
um
just it just may not be all that
familiar uh so the book of first peter
authored
by peter
apostle of jesus
uh
you probably guessed that one
by the name peter
um so it actually there's you know
there's various scholars who think maybe
someone else wrote it maybe it was like
um
kind of a community of peter and there's
they're kind of writing in his name you
know so those things it's possible but
um there seems to be pretty good reason
to believe it actually was
just literally peter the apostle
and he's writing probably around the
year about 64 maybe 65 a.d so this would
be you know maybe 30 years or so after
christ's resurrection and ascension
uh he's writing from rome
um which really impacts the the whole
book um and kind of shapes how we how we
read and interpret it so we know this
because he writes at the very end of the
book chapter 5 verse 13 he talks about
he says basically like i'm writing from
babylon
and
of course babylon at this time it had
been gone for hundreds of years so we
know it's not babylon like it's he's
using that term he's talking about rome
without saying rome much like actually
the book of revelation does that as well
someone talks about you know babylon and
very evocative language i won't i won't
quote the book of revelation it's
already intense um but it doesn't have
nice things to say about babylon we'll
just put it that way and uh and it's a
way of talking about rome so that's kind
of a common theme in uh in the first
century christians
so uh audience location
so he's writing from rome but he's
writing two christians in what we would
probably call just modern day
um turkey
so it's kind of that you know asia minor
kind of area
he's writing two gentile christians this
again becomes important later as we
start to interpret the book
you know who the audience is in their
own mindset kind of matters for how you
how you read it um so at any rate that's
uh their background they're gentile
christians not jewish christians
the audience contexts are facing some
mild persecution
this is why as we go throughout the book
you'll see the theme of suffering comes
up over and over and over i say mild
because
as best we can tell it wasn't that they
were necessarily being like killed for
their faith uh instead
they were um it was more like it was
just very socially unpopular to be
christian
and so they're facing a lot of you know
kind of slander and maybe even job loss
you know when people find out they're
christian you know things like that so
it was um kind of a stigma
in their their kind of wing of the world
to be a christian at this time
so all right so that's some of the the
background which um
i give you so that as we get into this i
think it'll help inform you know how we
read um and interpret this this text so
with that in mind the title of my
message tonight is strangers and seeds
strangers in seeds and we're going to
start with just verses 1 and 2 tonight
if you're wondering like how are we
gonna only get through chapter one in
five weeks well that's how just two
verses tonight so we'll start here peter
an apostle of jesus christ
to the exiles of the dispersion in
pontus galatia cappadocia asia and
bithynia who have been chosen and
destined by god the father and
sanctified by the spirit to be obedient
to jesus christ and to be sprinkled with
his blood may grace and peace be yours
in abundance
you ever wonder where i got that grace
in peace that's what i intend to open my
messages with and um i'm just
totally taking it from the bible
it's not custom to me
um
so i want to start by giving you just
kind of like my big idea for tonight and
this is sort of like the whole message
in just a few lines and then we'll kind
of unpack it sort of part one um well
let me give you let me give you the big
idea and then we'll get into it uh so i
believe that christians
um christians are called to be strangers
and seeds
strangers to the surrounding culture and
seeds of kingdom culture
um
because at the end of the day the book
of first peter it's it's really it's a
book written to a church community and
so they're really wrestling with the
question um what on earth does it mean
to be the church
like in other words you might say okay
jesus is lord
yes and amen awesome
now what
right like how should we then live what
what what now and and really
specifically um you know what does it
mean to be he'll use this language later
um a peculiar people that would be a
real theme of first peter what does it
mean to be like what's in other words
what's unique about christians
other than maybe like well we believe
some things like okay yes but like in
your living right what's different
what's unique what what's the what's the
call of god
like how does that actually look does it
make us look different at all you know
that's that's what they're wrestling
with um
so the answer of course i mean it's
elaborated if he gets into this you know
throughout the whole book um but i think
we get really the first kind of hint the
first little indication of what um he
what peter believes the church is called
to be and it's found in two words in
this opening
verse this is where he gives really what
we might call his ecclesiology
that's a very fancy theological word
just means basically your doctrine of
the church or your understanding of um
who the church is called to be what we
what she is called
to do
and we get it right here in verse one
when he looks at these christians from
turkey
and it's two thousand years ago and he
looks at them
and he opens by saying you
are
exiles
you are
in other words you are strangers in a
strange land you are
foreigners
that's his language
um it was literally um
here we'll read it again he says to the
exiles of the dispersion that's the key
words strangers and seeds which we'll
get into the seed part later
you are exiles to the exiles of the
dispersion in pontus galacia cappadocia
asia and bithynia
and so the reason it's a little bit
strange for him to open this way um is
because again think these are gentile
christians right if they were jewish
christians then you say oh i get it like
you know they're they're kind of jewish
roots so they were when babylon
conquered them they were scattered all
over the world and they're like longing
to return to the holy land you know to
jerusalem and so he says to the exiles
you know god is with you and ah it makes
sense and yet but that's the thing
that's why the audience matters they're
not jewish christians they're gentile
christians in other words all these
strange words that we read you know this
pontus galatia cappadocia asia but then
like these things don't mean a lot to us
but of course it meant a lot to them
that's called their home right like this
is this is because he's not even writing
just to one church he's running two of
the region so these are these are like
this is these are their homes
and so it's it's just it is it's a
little bit strange right for him to look
at him and his opening line is
to the exiles
it's a little bit like if i had to go on
a trip or something
and i opened it with this line brett
a pastor of jesus christ
to the exiled strangers of the
dispersion in sexy wily fate in
princeton texas
right you just be like
you're weird you know like why did you
what
you know like hello all you foreigners
in a strange land you know just like
what are
and the reason it's weird is because
we're not like we're not exiles we're
not like
born and raised here you know i mean
like and i imagine that's what
a lot of people i'm imagining these
christians 2000 years ago probably had a
very similar reaction where they're like
peter like why are you calling us you
know foreigners exile strangers we've
lived here our whole life in fact
honestly peter we're like very comfy
here
very comfortable here we like it here
and i think to that peter would say
exactly
too
comfortable
because he what he's getting at
is peter's naming that we so easily
get caught up in our kind of earthly
worldly sort of just the cultures that
surround us and it we just get pulled
right in
it's a little bit uh if you've ever been
in the ocean and like the tide you know
how it just like when it's really going
out and you're not even like trying to
go out to sea but all of a sudden if
that tide gets to pulling you it's like
you're swimming towards shore but you're
like the shore is not getting closer oh
gosh this isn't a good moment you know
anyone ever had a little bit of that
moment or where um i've used this
metaphor too or this picture where the
tide will kind of carry you down have
you ever done that like you've been
swimming in an area and you keep looking
up and every time right i'm leaving my
online people sorry i'm over here um
right it's like what's happening you're
getting pulled
down the shore and you like and you you
know you're swimming and you keep
looking up and it's farther and maybe
you had like a hotel that you know
started off like a way in the air and
all of a sudden it's like a little speck
in the disc what's going on it's just
pulling you out like that's the perfect
picture of culture right we just get
it's just it's the air we breathe it's
the waters we swim in it's just our
context we don't even think you don't
have to try
just it just happens and if you think
about it like we have actually a number
of cultures we've got texas culture in
all of its beauty and horror you know
i'm kind of crazy um we've got america's
broader american culture again with its
beauty and
not good at all at times right
completely antithetical to the way of
jesus we've got um
what else like even our kind of family
cultures
um even thinking of the way notice with
24 7 news and such like
the way that um kind of mass media has a
powerful influence right left right
center wherever you are
powerful right there's a whole kind of
culture of vibe in republican politics
right a certain way a certain vision of
the good life and a certain way of being
in the world that kind of calls people
to and the same for democrats right
there's a certain vision of the good
life certain values and things and there
can be beauty in these and also they can
be completely antithetical completely in
opposition to the way of jesus right but
what happens we just get we don't have
to think about it you know i mean you
just turn on your tucker carlson your
rachel maddow or whoever you and you
just listen to them over and over right
and it just sings it just pulls you
right out to see
right
yeah you can tell this series is going
to be real
right this i mean this is where i think
the bible it matters
riley he's speaking this isn't like whoa
how you're relevant like weird language
exiles the dispersions bible like he's
speaking right
to
us
and so what he's naming is that we get
so caught up in these cultures
that ultimately we end up leaving
christ's kingdom culture behind
or you might even say
um the whole time maybe even we're
calling ourselves christians and yet we
might even fail to like dip our toes
into christ's kingdom culture right what
he called the kingdom of god which is
sort of his vision of the good life his
vision of what human flourishing looks
like his kind of call for his people and
who we're called to be right like we
could say jesus jesus if some of you
remember the passage where he talks
about some will say you know many will
say lord lord you know he'll say i have
no idea who you are
right so what do you mean
it's like just said jesus i sing the
songs maybe even raise my hands you know
i don't know
right it's it's about a culture it's
about a call it's a it's about a way
of life here's how um
the theologian and philosopher dallas
willard put it which i
really loved alice willard if you need
like a good christian to read
find anything by dallas willard it's
wonderful uh he says this
uh the greatest issue
facing the world today
with all of its heartbreaking needs
is whether those who by profession or
culture are identified as christians
will they become disciples
students
apprentices practitioners of jesus
christ steadily learning from him how to
live the life of the kingdom of the
heavens into every corner of existence
in other words i think what he's naming
is that there are a lot of christians at
least we don't have to talk about the
world let's just talk about like our
context right the united states
there's like a lot of christians here um
in fact there was a pew research center
they did a
a survey back in 2020 and they found
that 65 of adults in the united states
identified themselves as christian
um
which is a pretty substantial number
like well
in fact in 1990 it was actually higher
back then in 1990 so 30 years back it
was um 85
but now it's kind of slick but still 65
now you're wondering well how many does
that translate to well there's 330
million people
in the united states
um roughly so a little math
had to do more math recently i got a
junior higher so i didn't realize you go
back to school as an adult
i didn't know you did that when you had
kids but turns out you do so a little
back of the napkin math so 65 of 330 is
million let that sink in 214
million christians
in just the united states not the world
like the united 214 million and now what
dallas willard is asking the question
he's saying okay so there's 65 214
million people are like yup team jesus
but he's asking the question yes but the
great the reason we have such a crisis
in our world is because
out of those 214 million how many people
are actually
saying jesus i want to live like you
lived
i want to love like you love
i i want um
your kind of patience
your kind of compassion your kind of
courage
the way you related to people i want to
relate just like that oh god would you
teach me how to do it every day would
you teach me how can you can you see the
difference between like ah sure team
view that's a christian
and
i want to apprentice myself to
you i want to be a student
of yours
that's a whole different level um
in other words it's much more
than simply getting saved
right as this is sort of the language
oftentimes in the culture it's sort of
like you know we need to get saved have
you been saved have you been saved
you'll actually notice if you stick
around the table for any length of time
i don't do like a whole lot of like
getting saved kind of messages or even
kind of getting saved like raise your
hand right now if you want to believe um
and i'm not opposed to those and
occasionally i will do that
but the reason i don't do a lot of those
is actually for this reason
that what we can have
well to put it in dallas willard's to
see it from his ankle we have a whole
lot of people in the united states quote
unquote getting saved right maybe
millions being baptized each year
far
fewer apprenticing themselves to jesus
christ
can you see the
the difference
right and this man this matters now you
might wonder like okay what did it mean
what would it mean to apprentice myself
to jesus this is sort of strange
language you know let me give you just
two like very easy steps
um first read and reflect on jesus words
i don't believe any christian like we
never mature or get too good
to simply
read the bible you know what i mean like
isn't it interesting we can kind of just
easily leave that behind or like well
i'm not really a bible person you know
and like okay but there is something
about like and and specifically
um
reading the four gospels right matthew
mark luke john
like keep those in heavy rotation
because other words how can we say like
i want to follow jesus you know and then
like
you know never read what he taught or
you know what i mean like that would be
a strange sort of i used this example
before too like imagine if you met like
um a buddhist say and so you if you know
anything about buddhism they're into
meditation and so you're talking the
buddhist you're like oh that's so
interesting you're a buddhist so tell me
about your meditation practice you like
meditate every day and imagine if
they're like meditation oh no no no i
don't meditate like oh
i thought you're a buddhist like oh yeah
i am but you don't no no meditator for
you no
never meditated a day in my life right
it would be a little bit like oh i was
hoping to meet like a real buddhist you
know what i mean um and i wonder if it's
similar right for us if they're like oh
you're a christian oh it's so
interesting so what's your favorite
teaching of jesus i'll bet you have a
favorite passage from the sermon on the
mount don't you chapter five six and
seven matthew oh tell me what's your
favorite one you know we're like uh
yeah sermon on the what sort of the
mountain you know um this can be a right
a real problem this is this is the thing
willard's naming of 214 million and and
just to be clear i hope you can see my
body language and my tone of voice i'm
not trying to shame anyone right that's
not my heart isn't like
you know but just to name hey y'all
like we're a church
and we need to like follow jesus and
stuff
you know like that's that's kind of the
the call here um so for example in um
coming back to the sermon on the mount
um
well actually before i get to that part
let me name this we're always already
apprenticing ourselves to someone
you know um for some of us it's our
facebook feeds
um tic toc feeds
i mentioned her earlier
old tucker or rachel
you know we have our various people that
we're kind of apprenticing ourselves too
but we're there are they're the voice
right and we have the ears for their
voice
right and so the question is
to what degree are we really doing that
same thing with jesus
and to what degree are we elevating his
voice above all other voices i think
that passage where he talks about hey
the sheep he's using the metaphor of us
as sheep he says the sheep know my voice
i know my voice do we know the voice or
is is his voices his christ's voice is
it getting drowned out
in all of the other voices and boy in
modern times do we ever have
all the other voices don't we i mean
imagine 2 000 years ago if you could get
a book
you know or a scroll it's like oh my
gosh i have information you know it was
like a special thing you had to go to
special places to like get information
you know today oh my gosh we are
drowning in voices
so we've got so it's about elevating the
voice of jesus and saying okay lord help
me to hear again help me hear and this
is why people often have a practice of
reading the scriptures either at the
beginning of the day or the end of the
day
or sometimes both right and what's it
it's about bookending right it's like
first thing in the morning i'm gonna
take in that voice or at the very end of
the day right before i go to sleep and
have all those dreams and the
subconscious churns and churns on
his voice right this is this is um
that's incredibly important that's step
one read and reflect on jesus words step
two we've gotta seek to live them out
makes sense right
we've all been around maybe um
christians or have been there ourselves
i've been there where you know you know
the words
you know the teachings
you do know matthew chapter five six and
seven and perhaps you've even memorized
it you know and yet you're a jerk
this is what you've known the you know
too many christians today out of the 214
million too many jerks that's what makes
me wonder like hmm are we really
apprenticing ourselves to jesus because
we seem real jerkish a lot of the time
you know and just to be here i'll throw
myself into that bus too like we've
we've been there hopefully though by
seeking to live them out
what happens and just to give you
something concrete like jesus says for
example do not be angry that's matthew
chapter five don't be angry
and so when we hear that as someone who
wants to apprentice ourselves to jesus
we say
okay
i'm gonna live into that
not perfectly
but i'm gonna i'm gonna try god by your
grace your spirit would you lead me and
fill me and help me to become a less
angry bitter person
right
that's or um
what else he said like do you not lust
um
do not um
don't hate your brother or your sister
he says do your best to be reconciled
relationally to everyone you can it's
also matthew chapter five all right so
this is what it means to be christian is
to like oh wow okay wow things really
have to change in my life right and i
think that's why coming back to peter
right this is why he's like yep too
comfortable
slowly over time the character of jesus
it becomes our character
even though
you still come from the same family or
you still live in texas or united states
what happens you start to become a
little bit
weird
in a good way
boy the united states we need some more
weird christians
in a good way
weird in their grace weird in their lack
of anger weird in their wisdom
weird in their patience
weird in their love
weird in their love for for justice and
truth
like oh
we need it don't we
um many of you know when we started uh
the table i want to give example of this
we started the table a few years back
and um
it was it was really it was difficult it
was a challenging season the the church
we came from um we had
and really continue to have very deep
relational roots there
um
and so
um i won't go into all the detail but
but there was basically there came a
time where we just knew we wanted to
start an inclusive church we wanted a
church home that um would be welcoming
of gay and lesbian folks and really
anyone from the lgbtq you know community
and so we we set out to you know start
this church but right before we did that
um
we had to really negotiate and navigate
the waters of how do we do this with our
previous community you know and how do
we um because they weren't necessarily
on the same page you know um and how do
we walk this out and you know when it
but there reached a point that when we
knew like we wouldn't be able to partner
with them in the same way you know not
like we were mortal enemies or something
we still love them deeply and they love
us but when we knew we couldn't it
wouldn't be the same you know we'd need
to kind of start a separate organization
um
right at the end of it right before we
launched the table we had um it was kind
of the maybe like say the patriarch he
might be the patriarch of the patriarch
because his he's the father of um a
leader at that church who's very
influential so he's sort of like the
spiritual grandfather of church
he invited my wife and i maggie
invited us over for dinner
and
i was like oh dinner okay yeah sure you
know i remember i'll never forget
walking up the steps to his house i mean
i've known this man for 30 years
you know since i was like seven so when
i've gone up the steps before you know
for like sunday lunches and things way
back in the day when i was a kid you
know
so it was strange like walk up those
steps and like oh my heart was just
oh i just i know i just didn't know what
to expect you know what i mean like
what's the vibe what's the tone what's
the thing what's the purpose why why are
we here exactly what's the what are we
doing i don't really know you know
oh just that that kind of moment i
remember we we walk in
and um he sits us down they'd ordered
some pizza and so we start munching on
pizza and making small talk you know
that awkward way you do if like you
can't just launch right in you know you
gotta kind of ease into you know so
small talk and then we start kind of
talking
and um and and pretty quickly as i knew
going in you know we weren't necessarily
on the same page
you know exactly um
on that kind of topic um
and yet as we got into it
it turned into a really beautiful and
profound conversation
um
because
really he never became reactionary with
us
the whole time
he like for example he would like ask us
questions
and like he was generally curious like
so talk to me about
what are you what are you not what are
you thinking and weird you know what are
you thinking not that but like so
explain like unpack it i want to
understand you know
and he starts asking questions and then
listening to us
imagine doing that in our culture like
asking questions with someone you
disagree with and then like waiting for
them to give an answer you know sort of
like the opposite of twitter
you know
um
so he never tried to manipulate us he
certainly never like blasted us
emotionally he didn't pressure us or
like try to like well i just think you
know like you didn't bring in the fear
thing you know the i just worried about
you know like he just the whole time he
was so gracious and patient
and
kind
and we finished that conversation and
literally we're getting towards the end
and he looks at me and maggie and he
says well
i just want you to know
that i love you very very much
and nothing will ever
change that
and i walk out his door and i thought to
myself you know what
we disagree and yet
i just experienced the kingdom of god in
that conversation
like i just
interacted with a man who has followed
jesus for a long time he's in his 80s
and he had apprenticed himself to jesus
christ
and it had done such a good
work in him god had done such a good
work in him that the character of jesus
had slowly but surely become his
character and so he could sit down with
someone
that he didn't completely understand
and yet
and yet the love of god could still like
shine from him
you know what's going on he was weird
in a good way
he was an exile a stranger
in a strange land
and that's essentially peter's point in
using this term
exiles he's saying oh church you
citizens of saxi and wiley and princeton
and fate and
kappel and we got people from all over i
won't try to go through all of them
he's saying remember that you are also
citizens of the kingdom of christ don't
forget that you are apprentices to jesus
christ
because if you become too mainstream
then what happens you can't be seeds
this is the second word he uses
in verse 1 peter an apostle of jesus
christ to the exiles
of the dispersion
the dispersion that goes through all the
cities you know pontus and galatia the
dispersion what's this a picture of so
the greek word here for dispersion is
diaspora
it's it's um the picture it means to be
sewn abroad so in the ancient world when
a farmer would sow their cedar or plant
they don't they didn't necessarily plant
in the way we imagine like oh okay they
dug a hole in the ground and then
dropped a seed and then covered it up
and you know they weren't like gardening
like that instead what they had was like
this satchel just full of seed i mean
almost down to the ground you know just
this heavy satchel seed and they would
dip their hand in grab a handful of seed
and just fling it out like that's how
they plan just
and that's what peter is naming is the
picture
he's saying what has happened god has
reached in his bag he's plucked you up
and he has whoosh
planted you
he's planted you all over the metroplex
and christians all over the world he has
dispersed us not being that that image
can be like oh my gosh it was like half
hazard you know but no no right it's god
we're talking about so don't stretch the
metaphor too far instead in fact
actually we'll get to this this is the
second verse right he looks at me says
because you you who have been chosen and
destined right that's not haphazard
right you have been chosen you've been
destined by uh god the father
sanctified by the spirit to be obedient
to jesus christ to be sprinkled with his
blood
but those are all metaphors in in the
language of of purification
and in a cleansing a healing other words
what he's saying is look god is doing a
beautiful healing cleansing life-giving
work in you
as you submit yourself to the kingdom to
kingdom culture to the ways of jesus and
then what he's gonna do he's gonna flang
you out and he's going to plant you to
bring life everywhere you go
that that's the image the exiles of the
diaspora of the dispersion you are
strangers and you are seeds
a planting of the lord
there's a passage i'll close with this
this is from isaiah chapter 61.
in the poet prophet isaiah he's foreseen
a picture of the people of god
and he says this
they
the people of god will be called oaks of
righteousness a planting of the lord for
the display of his splendor they will
rebuild the ancient ruins they will
restore the places long devastated they
will renew the ruined cities that have
been devastated for generations
and that beautiful what's he what's he
name and he's really asking us like
do you
do you realize you've been planted
and do you see that you've been planted
among some devastation
any devastated people
in your midst
and what about at work
at school
any devastated lives
devastated relationships
peter's naming isaiah's naming oh don't
forget
you're you've been called to be a little
bit weird
you've been called to be a stranger in
exile so that you can be a seed
so you can bring kingdom culture jesus
culture everywhere you
go
and so in so many ways this is our
mission this is our call as a church
it's not so much that we go to church
it's that we are the church right you
like wherever you go
the church is happening
church is in session right wherever you
go through the holy spirit like christ
is present
and that's the call
that's the call and so my my hope is as
we go through this book
that we could really start to grasp and
get into the details of what what would
it mean to be strangers to the
surrounding culture and then to
understand that we're seeds planted by
god
that's where we're going
i pray for you
lord jesus
we have been
too comfortable
too comfortable too accustomed to the
evil around us
two at peace with the venom and the
hatred in our culture too at ease with
the lies and the slander and the
backstabbing
holy god would you make a stranger to
these strangers to these evil ways
would you make us strangers to what is
worst in our culture
and as we apprentice ourselves to the
lord jesus make us seeds
seeds of peace in the midst of violence
and militarism
seeds of hope in the midst of despair
and a creeping meaninglessness that
threatens to swallow our culture whole
seeds of love and compassion when we are
tempted towards retaliation and
defensiveness
make us strangers and seeds lord
amen
[Music]
all right guys stand up with us real
quick stretch it out that was
a lot
of
good
[Music]
challenging words that were just said
and uh we're gonna go back around to
that first song that we sang multiplied
um noelle's gonna lead us again and i
just want you to pay attention to the
words that we're saying here what this
song is talking about is really being so
full of the love of christ that it's
actually changing us
it's actually doing something in us it
is
pouring out it is
going into the world around us it's like
radiating from us it's bursting from us
so let's just lean into that kind of in
light of what brett is saying let's be
changed by that love all right so you
guys sing it with us
[Music]
your love is
bursting inside of us
[Applause]
[Music]
like blazing wise
singing
[Music]
i have surrendered
stretch across the sky
[Music]
your love is
bursting inside us
we cannot
contain
[Music]
singing your name
got a mercy
[Music]
to your
desired
[Music]
church across the skies
be multiplied
[Music]
you'll sing it out with us
across the skies
[Music]
these
hallelujah
[Music]
let's lift it up sing it with us
hallelujah
hallelujah sing hallelujah
[Music]
all right
y'all thank you so much for being here
um with us tonight
and just a a quick reminder um that if
you're new here you can fill out there's
a little card right in the hallway we
have a little wooden box and some cards
you can just fill out your information
let us know you were here um i also send
out a weekly like an e-letter um and a i
sent out a prayer text so if you'd like
to be included in those
um just let us know in the comments and
just include you know that information
and we'll uh yeah keeping the loop on
that um also if you call the table home
um so not if you're visiting but if you
call the table home um we'd love for you
to um support your church family through
giving so you can do that there's in
that same little wooden box or of course
online through our website um finally we
have our trunk or treat event if you
want to sign up to decorate your car
trunk so that we make all the little
kids happy all those table kids who
wanted to be happy so there is um
marissa is right there in the back um
can you maybe hold that is that i think
that's the sign up yeah it's just right
there and there's a little table um so
if you want to decorate your trunk you
can do that we invite everyone if you
don't have kids please come out that
halloween night even though we're not
gonna have our regular service we're
gonna have like chili frito pie and you
know just be like a fun outdoor thing um
hopefully the weather is beautiful we
gotta we got a good chance in october uh
texas can be nice so um at any rate
that'll be halloween night we hope you
can join us so let me send you out with
this benediction
um you are god's servants
you're gifted with dreams
you're gifted with visions
and upon you rest the grace of god like
flames of living fire
go
love
serve the lord
in the strength
of the holy spirit
god be with you all have a wonderful
week